[Music]
the fallout from the nursing home
scandal
getting very serious from new york
governor andrew cuomo
the fbi and u.s attorney's office in
brooklyn
now reportedly investigating him and
senior members of his coronavirus task
force
it's over claims they covered up covet
deaths at nursing home facilities
cuomo insists he's done nothing wrong
but he is now facing growing bipartisan
backlash
one state democrat assemblyman ron kim
says the governor
bullied him and threatened to quote
destroy him
take a look when we get closer to the
truth behind the growing nursing home
scandal in new york
governor cuomo tries to implicate you in
the cover-up or threatens your
livelihood if you don't lie for him
and that's what happened to me in the
last one week for 10 minutes
uh he berated me uh he yelled at me he
told me
that you know my career will be over
he's been biting his tongue for months
against me
and i had tonight not tomorrow tonight
to issue a new statement especially
asking me to lie
and new york city mayor bill de blasio
he's backing up the idea that cuomo is a
bully
but that's classic andrew cuomo um a lot
of people in new york state have
received those phone calls
uh you know the bullying is nothing new
um i believe ron kim and it's very very
sad
jesse uh yesterday we were talking about
you know exactly what is the crime that
he did i don't think there's any
question he made grievous mistakes
but is it the case that somebody might
just say boy
those democrats in new york de blasio
now kim
are feuding with a powerful governor who
may be seeking a fourth term
oh there's a feud but cuomo started it
let's paint the picture juan
this guy ron kim democrat his uncle died
in a nursing home
that governor cuomo infected he's giving
his children a bath in his apartment in
queens the other day he's got
sleeves rolled up he's on his knees he
has the johnson and johnson no tears
baby shampoo here he gets a phone call
it's the governor
screaming so loudly that his wife can
hear and now
she's in tears because the governor's
demanding eli
threatens to destroy his career says
you're going to feel my wrath
and don't cross me and what else is the
governor going to do he's already killed
the guy's uncle
his wife's in tears but cuomo is not
stopping there
no he's called at least three other
state democrat lawmakers
threatened to destroy their careers for
trying to strip him of
emergency powers at least donald trump
when he called you out did it on twitter
in public
and he owned it governor cuomo does it
in the dark and secret and then he tries
to deny it
this is all about mario cuomo his father
and his legacy he was elected three
terms as governor new york
and his son he wants a fourth term but
he can see
that fourth term fading because you now
have federal investigations
public humiliation bipartisan outrage
so he's acting like a caricature of like
a tammany hall
gangster politician but he's coming off
more like a bully that got punched in
the face
and now his nose is bleeding and he's
wounded and whining about it and maybe
doesn't look so invincible
so it's gotten so bad that now zucker
over at cnn won't even let
chris his brother go near him
conveniently
because the governor's brand is too
toxic all of a sudden
it's getting it's getting rough let's
put it that way
i'm gonna i'm gonna ask greg about that
later but dana let me
ask you about the scandal reaching
washington because
now there's a letter from nine
republican senators
asking the senate judiciary committee to
have
merrick garland who's the nominee for
attorney general
commit commit that he will investigate
andrew cuomo i i'm wondering if that's a
little bit of
overreach by the republicans i mean
shouldn't an investigation be done
privately and without political pressure
i think it's pretty easy for merrick
garland to answer that question which is
it looks like the doj
and the u.s attorney's office is already
investigating and if i were
merrick garland i would say see no
reason to stop that
and move on and get confirmed that's
what i think will happen
i don't think that andrew cuomo ever
thought in his life he would be grateful
to senator ted cruz
until today because obviously
political news uh ted cruz is getting a
little bit of attention today for
something else we'll talk about in a
little bit
um look when when you're taking incoming
fire
from your own side to this great extent
there's no place to hide there's no safe
port in the storm
so i think that there's only one way to
let some air out of this political
balloon he either has to say something
like
um let me fess up here's what happened
or
more likely even this is even if the
democrats are going after him because
uh they're looking for him to topple so
that they can move up i mean the guy's
been governor
for three terms he wants a fourth i
think that's not going to happen
and if the governor wants to sort of
alleviate this situation he might
come out soon and say he's not running
again
that's an interesting thought but katie
to that point
this week we have a new poll from siena
a new york
state pollster and what they find is
that even after the scandal broke
cuomo's approval rating among new
yorkers is basically
unchanged and here's something i found
really interesting
it said 39 not a very high number
approve of how he made the data public
but 60 percent katie approve of his
handling of the pandemic what do you
make of this
well we've been talking about the andrew
cuomo
nursing home scandal for nearly a year
now
but not everybody has and so i think
that we're just at the beginning of the
real seriousness
of the consequences for what of what
he's looking at i mean we haven't seen
subpoenas yet from the senate in
washington d.c or from the local
legislature but we do have an fbi
investigation and i think it's going to
be really interesting to watch his staff
and how they react when they have to
lawyer up and they can no longer
call people and scream at them on the
phone because they're under
perjury rules and have the potential of
going to prison themselves if they lie
under oath to investigators
so while i think this is just beginning
i think the more people learn about it i
think his approval rating will go down
now also
you have to remember that before andrew
cuomo was saying this is just
republicans attacking me because i'm
running for governor again
well there's a lot of democrats who had
people who were killed
in nursing homes as a result of
government decisions
and so now everybody is asking questions
and it's not
really a political issue anymore it's a
matter of accountability
and finding out what happened after
andrew cuomo refused to release the data
to both republicans and democrats
yeah so greg jesse was talking about
the situation over at cnn chris cuomo
the governor's brother now
told to stay away from the story i think
we both agree there's an element of
entertainment
in cable news coverage and the the
sibling rivalry and the
cute the giant q-tip all was funny but i
was wondering just as a matter of
seriousness
now there's real news and a real scandal
isn't it appropriate to say that a
brother can't cover
a brother well that's i think
how as jesse said how convenient
so they had no issues with bro covering
bro when it was an adorable media
darling schtick
right when they played abbott and
costello or when they
had a block where they talked about
whether the governor was
uh single and ready to mingle it turns
out he was
he was ready to mingle he mingled
covered patients with rest home tenants
and killed him so let's face it they
should have done this sooner and that's
the big question imagine
imagine this if cnn had made that call
sooner and banned the bros right and
jake
tapper was doing the interviews and not
uh andrew cuomo
there'd be no q-tip there'd be no dating
tips perhaps the governor would have
acted faster under pressure from tapper
to reverse the policies and perhaps save
some lives so we have to ask how
culpable is cnn
in all of this perhaps the major cable
carriers
who bring cnn into your homes should
reflect
on whether that's a safe decision to
make
i mean i would definitely want to
revisit that and in lieu of
the bro scandal i suggest that chris
cuomo could cover another scandal that's
out there and brewing
you know the new york post was reporting
court papers that show
cnn paid 35 000 to a blm
anti-trump rioter who egged on the siege
of the capital
uh so they actually put a guy who
encouraged the siege
on tv and let him shape the narrative
that he helped make
and they paid him and they didn't
question his involvement
until others called him into question
that seems to me a pretty pretty pretty
big story
maybe now that chris cuomo has some free
time and he doesn't have to follow his
brother around
he could cover that story wouldn't that
be great
all right